was that did that feel like the biggest
thing that you had ever made happen
though yeah in terms of just bringing
like these two really big names together
yeah it was like kind of overwhelming I
didn't know if it would happen because I
was supposed to I was actually supposed
to go to Dubai and it's good that this
didn't happen because Brittany wasn't
gonna go to Dubai that was like too far
for her that's a really long flight
um but I was supposed to go there and
then my manager ended up getting
detained because he what's it called a
temporary passport they don't accept
those and my passport expires within six
months they wouldn't have let me in the
country so I actually bought a ton of
hotels flights like for people I did all
this stuff and then I had to cancel last
minute because I wasn't going to get in
the country and then Andrew said you
know I'll come to you and then I reached
out to Brittany and was like Hey I know
Dubai was too far would you want to come
to London and then she agreed and then
he agreed and then it was like five days
before he came I like put everything
together I got the girls and yeah